ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il ne
massacre pas les câbles tendus mais
déterminé isabelle fouillot n'aborde pas
sereinement les plaidoiries de la
défense à quelques heures du verdict
mais elle s'efforce de penser à l'avenir
j'espère pourquoi tourner la page et ne
pensait plus qu'à l'excellent mais c'est
d'abord emmanuel du pic l'avocat général
qui prend la parole il revient sur la
personnalité de johnattan décrit un
crime effroyable avant de se tourner
vers les jurés il leur demande d'être
courageux et requiert la prison à
perpétuité
il m'a semblé que dans cette affaire
épouvantable le calvaire qui a été subie
par alexis d'aval la façon dont elle est
morte
la crémation de son corps le mensonge
méritait effectivement
que cette peine soit requise ça prend
des ascendants avait parlé une très
grosse peine donc ça la passion
à la barre les avocats de la défense des
peigne à leur tour un johnattan effacés
fuyant il n'avait jamais été violent
lance m gr dorfer avant de s'adresser
aux jurés le meurtre d'alexia n'est pas
un féminicide ce n'est pas un crime de
possession ça vous arrangerait tellement
juger c'est comprendre pas excusé
fatma de toute façon la peine n'apaise
pas la peine en ce sens que la sanction
n'apaise pas la souffrance et c'est pas
dieu merci c'est ça revient à la société
de punir et jamais la victime avant les
délibérations de johnatan d'aval doit
s'exprimer une dernière fois
il veut s'adresser à ses beaux-parents
je ne fais pas du tout c'est pas nul ne
prépare pas fait les prises de paroles
très jeune à thann se lève et ne
prononce aucun mot
pardon pardon dit il la main sur le
coeur en regardant les parents d'alexia
la cour prononcera finalement une peine
de 25 ans de réclusion criminelle
[Musique]